en vídeos anteriores vimos a la luz
entrando o saliendo de medios más lentos
por ejemplo tenemos esta superficie esta
superficie y aquí abajo tenemos un medio
lento con un rayo de luz que va saliendo
así y este rayo de luz tiene un ángulo
de incidencia voy a dibujar aquí una
perpendicular tiene un ángulo de
incidencia de 1 y la forma en la que
pensamos en esto es haciendo un lado la
forma en la que realmente funciona la
luz imaginar que aquí tenemos un
vehículo que pasa de un medio lento que
este es el medio lento
a un medio más rápido
por ejemplo que pasa del lodo a una
carretera asfaltada en este ejemplo la
inclinación del rayo o del auto entre
comillas hará que las llantas de aquí
del lado izquierdo lleguen primero al
asfalto y comenzarán a moverse más
rápidamente por lo que harán que este
auto gire hacia la derecha más o menos
así de manera que el rayo cuando salga
va a tener una inclinación así como se
muestra aquí y este segundo ángulo voy a
expandir aquí la perpendicular este
segundo ángulo es teta 2
este es el ángulo de refracción y en
este caso el ángulo de refracción va a
ser mayor que el ángulo de incidencia
cuando pasamos de un medio lento hacia
un medio rápido lo que quiero que
encontremos es si existe algún ángulo
dependiendo de estos dos materiales en
los que viaja la luz
un ángulo de incidencia lo
suficientemente grande que llamaremos
este ángulo de incidencia más grande
que llamaremos theta 3 en el que el
ángulo de refracción alcance a ser de 90
grados es decir que el ángulo o el radio
a ser refractados se vaya por la
superficie y no salga hacia el medio
rápido que el ángulo de refracción sea
un ángulo recto de 90 grados y más aún
si yo tuviera un ángulo de incidencia
más grande que este ángulo 3 de manera
que la luz ni siquiera puede viajar
sobre la superficie en el que la luz va
a ser reflejada de regreso al medio
lento a este ángulo 3 lo llamaremos
ángulo crítico o theta c pues cualquier
cosa más grande a este ángulo no tendrá
refracción no podrá escapar de este
medio lento este rayo se va a reflejar
de vuelta a este mismo medio
ahora vamos a realizar esto con un
ejemplo digamos
y aquí tengo agua que tiene un índice de
refracción y esto es agua con un índice
de refracción de 1.33 y digamos que aquí
arriba tengo aire aire el cual tiene un
índice de refracción bastante cercano al
del vacío de vídeos anteriores sabemos
que el índice de refracción del aire es
1.000 29 pero en este caso por motivos
de simplicidad diremos que su índice es
igual a 1
ahora lo que quiero hacer para la luz
que sale del agua que voy a dibujar acá
la luz que sale del agua quiero
encontrar un ángulo crítico vamos a
dibujar la perpendicular a esta
superficie que me queda un poquito
chueca vamos a encontrar el ángulo
crítico o theta ce en estas condiciones
este ángulo crítico ocasionará que mi
ángulo de refracción sea de 90 grados un
ángulo recto de manera que el rayo de
luz no salga hacia el aire sino se
mantenga aquí en la superficie del agua
es decir si tengo un ángulo de
incidencia menor a este ángulo criticó
que de hecho voy a escribir bien la cee
porque no se nota se de crítico
ángulo de incidencia menor a este el
rayo de luz va a salir al aire si tengo
un ángulo de incidencia mayor a este
ángulo crítico el rayo de luz jamás va a
salir de la superficie
y va a tener una reflexión total interna
de manera que se verá reflejado en este
mismo medio así que veamos cómo podemos
obtener este ángulo crítico de tasé
usemos nuevamente la ley de snl vamos a
escribir los valores que sabemos tenemos
el inicio de refracción del agua que es
un 1.33 por el seno del ángulo de
incidencia que queremos encontrar en
este caso el ángulo crítico y esto va a
ser igual al índice de refracción del
aire que aquí quedamos que es 1
uno por el seno del ángulo de refracción
que en este caso queremos que este
ángulo sea igual a 90 grados que esto
sea 1 por el seno de 90 grados y cuál es
el seno de 90 grados pues recordemos
nuestras fórmulas trigonométricas y
usemos nuestro círculo unitaria vamos a
dibujar aquí estos ejes y el círculo más
o menos así de manera que aquí mide 1
y aquí también mide uno tiene un radio
de una unidad el pse no va a ser esta
coordenada y por lo que el seno de 90
grados que son estos 90 grados va a ser
igual a 1 así que esto es 1 x
va a ser igual a 1 dividimos ambos lados
entre 1.33 y nos va a quedar que el seno
del ángulo crítico va a ser igual a 1 a
este 1 entre 1.33 y si queremos
generalizar esto esta parte de arriba va
a ser el índice de refracción del medio
más rápido este va a ser el índice
de reflexión del medio rápido
y el de abajo va a ser el índice de
refracción del medio lento
pues siempre buscaremos el seno de 90
grados para nuestro ángulo crítico y nos
quedará que el ángulo crítico nuestro
ángulo de interés va a ser igual a el
seno inverso
1 / 1.33 sacamos nuestra calculadora y
escribimos esta cantidad 1 / 1.33
a esta cantidad le vamos a sacar el seno
inverso y nos queda que es 48 puntos 75
grados aproximadamente 48.8 vamos a
escribir lo que este ángulo crítico es
aproximadamente igual a 48 punto 8
grados lo que nos dice que si tenemos un
rayo de luz que sale del agua con un
ángulo mayor a estos 48.8 grados no
podrá salir fuera del agua se va a
reflejar en este límite si tenemos
ángulos menores al 48.8 entonces la luz
se va a retractar y podrá escapar del
agua y cambiar un poco su dirección y si
el rayo de luz tiene justamente este
ángulo tendremos un ángulo de refracción
de 90 grados con el que rayos irá por la
superficie del agua y nos saldrá y justo
esta es la forma en la que funcionan los
cables de fibra óptica ustedes pueden
imaginarse los cables de fibra óptica
como
tubos o tuberías de vidrio y los ángulos
de incidencia de la luz que viaja por
ellos son tales que la luz se va a
mantener dentro del cable se va a
reflejar aquí dentro
en todo el camino de la fibra óptica
espero que este vídeo les haya sido de
interés